now you are on video so it must stay good
so let's introduce caterina and her
debut practically this is my debut
on television
catarina
[Music]
when I hear this title I remember the
story of this song
the candidate song for the
sanremo festival that I had to arrive at my house  to face
shortly thereafter and I said this song is not
good because the festival is a competition and
this is not a song made for a
competition it is a song that deepens a
timeless song but it is not made for
a competition in fact then I let myself be
convinced  the song went to sanremo and
arrived only fourth then afterwards it
did all the way that everyone
knows
the day after the famous boxing match
between his opponent remained
the song leaps to the top of the
rankings in germany maybe a
week later
leap in the head  to the ranking in
France and shortly thereafter to Canada and so
on and so on, it soon came really first
in the ranking in practically all the
markets of the  almost and eastern world and has
truly entered fully among
those songs that can be defined
evergreen
[Music]
and this naturally generates confidence,
optimism, general euphoria in me but
also all those who worked with me
for me
misery was my real first big
Occasion Zucchero wrote to this
song thinking of a duet with
Maestro Pavarotti certainly not with me there was a
need for more to play the
part of which would then be
destined for the Maestro they called me yesterday if
you create why not and from there it all started
and  I think this is my
very personal opinion that all this
happened because it had to happen because
you wanted all this where you can
what you want
[Music]
I don't think there is a favorite part
the song I listened to as a whole
then I  I think the song is magical
as a whole and this contrast between
the operatic way of singing and
today's pop that creates this magic
and that created it s  especially then
because up to that moment such
a thing had never been heard
[Music]
this too the prayer was a
particularly lucky moment in my
career
one of the highest and most
exhilarating moments because it saw me next to
it where I was  a big fan
because céline's voice is an instrument
from that occasion a
great friendship was born between me and her that
still lasts today esteem and friendship
[Music]
celine had the unfortunate idea of saying that
amous phrase that has remained historic by now
to say in one of her specials in which I
participated if god had a voice he
would have the voice of andrea this thing
that she said I imagine in a
naturally joking way went around the
world and was the reason for the opportunity
of 1000 1000 1000 questions on this thing
via rose great masterpiece that dpa
sang in an incomparable way with
his vibrant voice full of pathos we
decided to record this piece a
bit also memory of this g  great
artist recording it came the idea of
it become a duet there at least
to have the voice of veronica next to mine and t
erefore when I think of this
ong the moment we call her always comes to mind, askin
her to br
ng him a coffee to which  we play a
bit treacherously she brought us the coffee and
then we asked her to record her
part telling her that then we would find
a singer in her place instead she did it
well her voice remained in the record I
sing my
[Music]
uses is a song that  I recorded
my first album collected some
unreleased songs not many and since we still did not have
enough material for an
entire album of unreleased songs it ended with
a part of a concert that I did in the
theater in which I sang operatic pieces of
course this song and it was
particularly good  fashion at the time also
lent itself to my voice
so we plan to record it and the more I
think about it it is said that I made with a
great air that I met at  my house here
in miami and which I found myself in
fantastically because she is a
young and nice girl was and is today a
darling my children and on the occasion
I made a kind of joke matteo who
arrived in miami from italy just the
day in  which arianna was my house and he
did not know it
so he opened the door enters the house and with
me he found ariana grande after a few
years but I was still a kid and of
course his surprise was
credible so from this collaboration
was born the recording of this
beautiful song according to  me
ass
[Music]
then the title of the song is volumes and I
would be happy if matteo came here to
talk about it too comma
ter arte sony scott foley experience
trained in the studio this song
came ahead of time because I was hoping
that matteo had  still patience
says he is studying he is a
conservatory student and I hope he will sign his
studies
no exposition then to the very
modern function very actual  which is therefore
part of Matteo's world more than
mine the verse he sings I have to be
honest is sung better by him than by
me because because I liked a song that is
part of his
world very much there are
very sophisticated harmonies  that are not
played by ear
like this after the first listening but you have to
really get there and about and understand them
and then to the complete song beautiful
inspired and well built
under happy to have been able to share
with you part of my life
in short, some beautiful memory of my
past
I am also happy to have introduced
Caterina to you and I hope that she will bring us
luck too thanks then a greeting a
hug to everyone and soon
[Music]